all right it's 1005
let's get started uh good morning
everyone
um i would be kind of your host for
today i'm narita
i'm so glad that you've all made it
bright and early this friday morning
thank you for joining us for today's
serious play
session really to understand the
methodology behind
clay and achieving outcomes for
creativity and innovation
um today's session has been curated
really for the intent of engaging
participants
across multiple platforms so again and
the last reminder
for those who have just joined us please
use your mobile device to scan the qr
code on the bottom right of the screen
or go to mentee.com with the password
858220 for the upcoming polling session
you are in once you see angela and
darwin's lovely faces on the manti meter
screen
as angela is demonstrating
um today's session is organized by in
vitro
innovation in partnership with pxd labs
and paperwork and is supported by design
singapore council
the national agency for design in
singapore
here at the national design center
this is initiative is part of national
design center's
program lineup in july with a thematic
focus
on power play we are happy to be
invited to contribute towards this
course on how
power of play in design can make work
and life better and more fun
more information on the program lineup
will be shared
in the later part of today's session
i'm narita your host for today i am the
co-founder of paper space
a collective of strategists interior
designers and architects
who come together to deliver projects
for clients
we have also established paperwork a
co-working space for design premiers
here in the home of the national design
center
this is really how we got to first meet
angela corke
our lead facilitator today
we hosted lego serious play workshop
during singapore design week
in march last year my how the world has
changed since then
and has continued our journey with this
methodology
to develop strategies and alignment for
our business
as well as our stakeholders i'm
personally fascinated to see how the
method
unifies differing viewpoints through an
extremely engaging and fun session
so without further ado i would like to
introduce
our two incredibly certified
facilitators from lsp who will be
leading you
in the two breakout sessions as well as
the main forum
angela [ __ ] from south africa
helms from a background of brand
strategy for 20
years she has now been in singapore
20 years of her life so i think she's
south how old am i then that you've just
made me very old narita
um of a brand strategy
she was working with um incredible
agencies like tbwa
sachi and leo burnett to name a few
uh before courageously venturing into
setting up her own practice
in vitro 11 years ago to focus in the
area of innovation
her key clients include pizza heart
media corp
and the lvmh group
our second facilitator is darwin
antipolo
from the philippines that's also been in
singapore for a long time
his background is equally colorful and
the opposite of angela
he devoted 25 years of his professional
career
in digital marketing and transformation
for organizations like aberdeen crayon
and united laboratories
he now leads pxd labs an agency
specializing in crafting user journeys
uh with lsp methodology
so over to you angela um and before that
let me just run through the agenda for
the day
yes that'll be good that would be good
um so we just
said the welcome session um the next
session it really gets really
interesting
uh where we're gonna take um the play
innovation with serious play
through a live simulation uh for all
participants
before then breaking out into two
breakout rooms
in the two breakout rooms uh one will be
led by angela
and one will be led by darwin once that
session ends in about
about 20 minutes we come back to the
breakout room
to the combined main room again to
continue on
what that experience looks like and that
will be led by darwin
we would like to have time to address
any other
burning questions in the q a forum at 11
10 before passing it over to design
singapore paul salvaraj so without
further ado angela
over to you thank you wow
it's phenomenal to see firstly some
familiar faces
friends from very long ago i have some i
see some faces from hong kong days back
in
2005 been in the region as narita said
for a long time
um and obviously met many folks
and and happy to see some familiar and
new faces here today
so to kick us off i thought we would get
going on the mentee meter
and basically as i said you should have
had the
hopefully this is on your mobile phone
and
um i'm going to just load the the survey
and get us
just getting a couple of questions up um
and let's see where you're coming from
um you should be seeing the first
question now
which is so this is just a little sort
of open a question for
everybody and it should be appearing on
your
smartphone and it basically says which
brick speaks to you so just pick one
which you think
is speaking to you right now
and then i will pull up the result to
see
where we all stand
okay and you can see people are putting
the inputs in
a couple of bricks there we've got a
couple of plants doing super well
um but the red window is
charging ahead as well um and of course
our little vehicle with the wheels
is coming along as well so just a little
little exercise to say to you guys you
know even
uh something as simple as a brick can
actually connote
uh some thoughts and feelings can even
give you a sense of how you're feeling
right now
um and just again just to sort of
practice this using of menti meter
i thought we would then ask you one more
question with relation to these bricks
um and it is what is it saying to you
so i in a in a perfect world i could ask
about all nine or so of these bricks but
we don't have time
so i'm gonna just pull up one and say
what is the red window saying to you and
i'd like you to just put in
a couple words into the next slide you
should be instructed to push along to
the next question
and just put in a couple thoughts and
let's see
what is the red window saying and the
word cloud of
inputs i can see
lots of things coming through
opportunity seems
big perspective openness
[Music]
window to the world and so forth and so
forth and you can see as
more um inputs are coming in that
that word cloud is getting a bit crazy
there but basically
i think the message i have for you is
that something as simple
as a lego brick
can actually have meaning right and
obviously a window
has a lot of um metaphorical elements to
it
and of course later when we do the
legacy session you'll see that
these bricks actually do have meaning
they they provoke certain thoughts and
people
um and we really just tapping into that
for our serious play session
so i'll leave that one for now and
to let's check where we're all coming
from of course this is a session
on uh serious play as well as design
thinking and how we can sort of bring
these two together
um and i had a couple questions i want
to know what you guys what's your
relationship with these two topics
how much familiarity do you have and
that'll just give us a sense of where we
stand
and if i just give me a sec i want to go
on to the next one
so first question is about design
thinking
so what is your experience with design
thinking and i really just want you to
choose one response and let's see
uh where we where we lie the options
being no
knowledge some knowledge never heard of
this thing
maybe you've even participated in a
design thinking project
maybe received some training you might
even be
a expert in design thinking so
just interesting to see where we lie
most people saying they've got some
knowledge
a couple haven't really heard of it well
hopefully we
we sort of close that loop for you today
um some have even facilitated projects
we've got 22 percent
23 percent um have have done that so
that's phenomenal
yeah so that's that's a good spread
right um but good that most of you have
obviously heard of it
we're going to be using sierra's plan
connecting at design thinking so
explaining how serious play can
contribute
and we have one more question for you
and this is about
serious play
so let's go on to this one which is
what is your experience with this term
serious play
and again you just select one
and let's see where you guys are
so many of you very unfamiliar never
heard of
serious play well we're gonna definitely
change that today
some knowledge i've been trained
in a serious play method i know who that
is
um or i've even experienced a workshop
in that so
uh that's cool but most of you i think
probably a bit more familiar with design
thinking
a little less familiar with with serious
play and that's really helpful
for us okay cool so i'm going to leave
them anti-meter for now you can just
leave it open
leave the phone off to the side and
we will have a couple questions later
but for now
we go back to our main session
and let's talk about this play and
innovation
okay um so where i'm coming from is
really this idea that
innovation and the way in which we sort
of find new opportunities has changed
radically
over the last sort of ten years or so
and maybe even the sort of
things have sort of come undone a little
bit and we're having to include lots
more people in the conversation about
what opportunities we want to go after
and what what those specific things
might be
um and it really has required a little
bit of a rethink in terms of how we work
and how we discover new opportunities
for our company
to to innovate there's really just a
very simple way of looking at things
which is to say
if you think about how we normally work
in the world of work as we know it it's
very efficiency driven
and what i mean here is we very task
oriented we've be
we've sort of optimized work so that we
can get
lots of things done in a short period of
time
and it's very good at exploiting
opportunities that have already been
discovered and so
you know a business model has been set
up we have figured out to our customer
is our product and we're now exploiting
that
and that's really how most work has been
organized the problem is
that we need to look for new
opportunities this requires a different
kind of focus and this is really where
we want more work that's around
emergence
and emergence is really about exploring
and saying what can be
you know what is what is what is missing
in our customer's life or what is the
opportunity in our category
an emergent work really requires a
little bit more of sort of meandering
exploring opening up the imagination and
it doesn't work in the same way as
efficiency work
it's hard to marshal it and say arrive
now we have 30 minutes and now we need
our next big idea
it needs a little bit more time and
space and the right conditions need to
be set
for um for this work to happen and so
what this is where we feel
play has a huge opportunity that we can
put people in a more creative
innovative mode and serious play is one
way in which we can really bring out the
imagination
and so this is our focus and our
interest today
so just to give you a little definition
of what this is because i see a lot of
you are not familiar with the term
in fact it it was born around 1995 and
in fact lego were one of the early
originators of the term essentially what
it means
is you create a playful environment
so that new ideas and new and new things
can emerge
and so it's really creating that space
where people
feel like they're having a playful time
they don't feel like they're doing heavy
strategic or innovation work
and it really allows things that
normally would be inaccessible
to to emerge the term sorry
probably came around in 95 and in year
2000 there was a book written
by a guy by the name of michael shiraj
called serious play
i've got it over here and this was a
really a seminal book
on on serious play and it was around
sort of how to use prototyping
and and sort of experimentation and
playfulness
and that was so that's 20 years ago now
that the term is
has really been um with us
i would say in terms of methodologies
there are many methods that fall into
serious play but
probably the most famous would be the
lego series play method
and we're going to show a little bit
about that but we're going to talk about
some of the others
as well so in terms of how lego series
play
and serious play come together with
design thinking
design thinking is really a phenomenal
methodology if we're going to be
including a lot of people
into innovation it's a great way to
create an accessible way for people to
participate in innovation
and when you add a serious play element
to it you really just sort of
take it to the max in terms of
energizing people
getting people to lean in and contribute
you know innovation can be intimidating
and when you bring serious play into the
equation
you take it down to a more human level
and
people are feel hey i can do this you
know when you when you bring lego bricks
into a workshop
everybody feels this is something i can
do but when talk about strategizing
and sort of heavy innovation lifting
people feel like they can
they need to retreat from that and so
serious play really
in a way and engages people and says
come come play
let's um let's do something together
so lego series play being the probably
the most
uh popular and and certainly the leading
edge methodology
darwin and myself both are lego series
play facilitators
and effectively what this is it's taking
the lego that we're all familiar with
that we might have played with
as kids and bringing it into the
boardroom bringing into the meeting room
lego really pursued this because they
felt at the time in the mid 90s lego
wasn't actually doing so well
that their managers lacked imagination
that they weren't being
creative in their solutions and the
thinking was how can we bring this thing
that fires up the creativity of kids
and and bring it to the world of adults
so how lego serious play actually works
is
we we give a question and then we ask
the participants to build
a model in response to that question
after that there is some storytelling
that happens about what have you built
and then some reflection that happens so
in terms of the actual process
it takes several hours maybe as short as
two or three but often the workshops
that darwin and myself run
might be sort of more like a day or a
day and a half and even two days
depending on how complex the topic is
so what we're going to share with you
today is very much a simulation of that
process
it's really to give you a flavor and
of course being virtually adds another
dimension to the whole process
because you know when you walk into a
room
full of bricks people's energy changes
you know they they light up they become
sort of kids again they know they're
there to play
and so in a way we get we get a huge
helping hand as facilitators
when people walk into a room and go ha
lego
but of course in a virtual world it is
possible to build um
and and there are a couple of hacks and
workarounds that we use
um but obviously a slightly different
experience basically lego is used for
any kind of communication or problem
solving
so where you want people to think about
an issue deeply you want them to lean in
and contribute
and really it unlocks knowledge that's
sitting latent in people's brains
okay so you hopefully a little bit later
you're going to see
exactly how how that works
in terms of where lego series play has
its most benefit
if you think of the design thinking
process sort of following these stages
of starting off with an understanding of
the customer
or the empathizing stage then sort of
synthesizing that into some problem
understanding or problem reframe
then jumping into where can we go with
this what's the new
opportunity what's the idea and then
trying to
experiment around how to manifest that
idea into prototype and then obviously
to put that in front of customers and
test so there's maybe most of you are
familiar with sort of that
the five-step process or thereabouts
essentially there is an emergence phase
which is at the beginning which is sort
of like
trying to understand what's going on and
what can be and then later on there's an
exploitation phase
and and certainly lego serious play
is very strong in the front end of that
process
so where you're trying to understand the
customer trying to understand what
challenge or problem
we should tackle and even generating
ideas
lego series plays very very strong i've
never used it on the prototyping and
validation side and i'm sure maybe some
people have
if you're simply using it for
communication it definitely would have
some value there but
we say at the front end at the more
confusing end
lego series play probably has the
greatest impact
okay so this is something that i can
talk about for days but quite frankly i
may not give you any greater clarity on
how this process really works
this is really best experienced and i
know that
we had about 25 30 people
who registered for the lego session
it is difficult to do this with 100 or
150 people
typically we need one facilitator to
about 10 people
so we thought we'd do a simulation today
and for the simulation
what we're going to do is we're going to
go into two breakout rooms
darwin will manage one room i will
manage the other
hopefully for those of you that did sign
up for the lego session you've got your
lego handy it should be
hopefully sitting in front of your
computer and we're going to ask
that those folks who are playing lego
clearly
identify yourselves by renaming yourself
in the zoom you can do it at the top
right of your video
of your video box i just say lego in
your name
and everyone else is going to be an
observer for the session and so we ask
that you
turn your video off as well as your
audio and sort of just hang back
and observe what is going on the
session's only going to take about 20
minutes
um so not very long and then we will
return to the main session and have a
discussion
around that okay so
we have i think we have my group back in
the main room
um and i think we're just waiting for
darwin and his crew to come back we'll
do a debrief and and
we're back sorry whoa timing darwin
awesome
yes how was that darwin oh
um i find it uh
different and exciting to be like
facilitating in this way and virtual but
i i
i'd like to hear from our participants
cool so i'm gonna screen share guys um
and let me just pull up um
we were like majorly multitasking
so you should be seeing um
[Music]
so while we were in session and darwin
and now normally we wouldn't multitask
to this level if we're facilitating lego
series play
um you would have someone else doing it
next to us but anyway for the interest
of our demo
what was happening is the participants
built their models
um we were taking some notes on the key
sort of points that they made
and we also took some images of the
models being built and the individual
captures as well
so there's my team we tried to i
well this was very challenging for me
doing a screen grab while holding up a
model and getting all of these things
going but we managed to achieve it and
basically on this question so we had
this question around when you are doing
online shopping particularly in a local
retail sense
what is it that you want from that
experience and darwin maybe i'll just
share a little bit that came from
um from my guys um we had a lot of
mentions around the human connection
looking for a happy experience the joy
of shopping
um maybe i could call on can i call
on that no lisa are you still there
hi show everybody your model no lisa
tell them what what
what you built yeah
yeah cool yeah just tell us what you've
built and what does it mean in the in
the context of online shopping
um i was looking more at um a micro
experience for myself
so uh it has it started off with our
tower but it has this branches on top
because
my online shopping experience is that
i'm normally focused by one thing but i
branch
out to buy many other unrelated things
but i did try to make myself a bit more
responsible and look for
environmentally friendly things green
things so i added
a little plant right on top yeah cool
good
well done good so look that was a very
quick process guys
um it was like you know
rapid fire um lego series play normally
i think i think darwin and i we might
get sort of excommunicated from the lego
series play community
for doing so fast um but don't tell
anybody okay
don't tell anyone um i'm gonna sort of
move on from here darwin because i think
it's a
sort of time like i'm watching the clock
here a little bit
but that's kind of how it goes and of
course uh there is a lot more detail to
it and if you're keen to know more just
reach out to us we'd be happy to share
more
um just to just to wrap up on lego
series play what makes it powerful
is that it gets knowledge out of people
so it's latent in people's brains maybe
not even so conscious
um but the bricks provoke and we we sort
of
are able to elicit a response
particularly because we're dealing with
metaphor
also language is so ambiguous and
sometimes verbally it's hard to explain
what's going on in the company or
complex system and so the the visual can
be very powerful
um and it's very memorable you know
someone can
present a model and even weeks later you
remember
what that meant and who said it and why
so that's that's very very powerful as
well
okay um this is what a session looks
like
you know it's normally a bit more
intimate we we like one facilitator to
10 people
but you can obviously have bigger groups
and more facilitators
uh we pick the bricks we build our
models sometimes we write post-its
um and we create sometimes a shared
model we we
we try to have a common understanding of
what everyone feels or thinks about a
particular topic this was one i did
and i've done several for lvmh here in
asia pacific
in terms of design thinking um what we
can do
is we can use these models to build
where we would normally put a post-it on
a
on a flip chart or on a poster we can
ask people to build
obviously building takes a bit longer
than just writing something on a post-it
so you've got to be careful about
how much lego you can add to the process
but you could do like a journey mapper
you know some kind of a user journey
and maybe you just build the models to
identify the pain points along the
journey for example you don't have to
build
the entire thing okay so that's just to
show you a little example of how
how we use it if you feel like you
really want to uncover
something that is latent that's not
really on the top of sort of people's
tongues
then i think lego really is very
powerful in in doing that
okay so that's lego series play done i'm
going to hand over
to darwin to talk a little bit more
about uh leg
sort of serious play more broadly darwin
off you go i'm going to stop sharing
okay great so um
[Music]
we angela and i um have been
utilizing um this design thinking in
in our in our practice um
hers is on innovation and branding and
mind in service and experience design
um what has been apparent uh i believe
is that that we use serious play
uh to enhance the
quality of the engagement with with the
team
amongst the members of the team in going
through
a fairly difficult probably design
thinking journey or
in going through the challenges what
we've done
angela and i have identified seriously
yes including lego series play and what
are the attributes that
make make what make an activity um
categorized as a
serious play so what we looked at
is like when an activity um
an activity is making us build uh and
make
um yes it is serious play and when we
see
that we um infuse symbolism
into objects uh into it we are
using metaphor um using the power of
metaphor in in doing that and then we
we see activities that are created out
of
making stories and telling stories as a
good attribute or foundation
to be for that to be categorized as
serious play
um and also when when we start from an
individual
and it becomes a shared experience um a
shared experience with
uh other others in the group
then it is also serious play
then we we then we move into
role play and simulation where um
we answer the question of what if in
building worlds
that may not be there and then we we see
provocation when when you when you're
sensorially um
challenge um using your eyes your your
senses
um your auditory your kinesthetic
you are provoked into that when
it all it is also um asking us to be
spontaneous
and be unpredictable um it is seriously
when lastly when we're solving problem
creatively uh these are the attributes
of
serious blame methods that we've
encountered so
we have um lego seriously there and
these are
human centered qualities that we
that we have what what has
happened also is that um we've
looked at references in
in fahrenheit
we've already heard from uh
angela mentioning um serious play from
michael schrock
uh but also we'd like to like call out
um
this book from christians and erasmus
and building better business using lego
serious play method
um as also a a good reference when
you're looking at
the bigger picture in serious play of
course we won't be talking about
seriously
if we don't um reference the
classic work of um dr stewart brown
uh in his you know classic book called
play
and it gives us a snapshot of the mind
at play these two books uh innovation
in game storming we'll have a peek at
that uh
later after this live and just lastly to
round off
some of the references that you know you
might want to put in your library
uh when you are exploring play there's
thinker toys by mikhail ko
of course dibono would always be there
in your library we've chosen or we
gravitated towards how to have
creative ideas by edward dibono and we
have two appearances
from uh carl capp on play to learn
and gamification uh field goal the last
one i must tell you the gamification of
learning and instruction field book is
quite hefty
i have not yet finished uh me going
through it
but one interesting thing that is new in
my library
at least would be jane mcgonagall
looking at it from
a futurist perspective is broken but
she's narrow it down to gain
in gamification so let me just
move on to that as i've shared and
promised you
let's have a look at an insight of game
storming this
is primarily classic when everyone talks
about serious play or serious game
the this book led by dave gray
is a reference for many facilitators or
many people that are involved
with uh with serious play or exploring
it if you look at it there's about
80 80 games within within the book
and if we scroll down in some of the
some of the activities that are there
these are familiar
activities or serious games for us and
you might say
hey there's a swot analysis there uh
yep and there's a racy matrix there see
when we looked at the
different serious play in the series
serious game
universe and we line it up with
attributes that we mentioned a while ago
then
these activities um fall under serious
play
where also lego seriously falls into
place
looking at the other book from
innovation games by this one i think
angela and i are like
wow fantastic in fact i call this like
the
yeah there you go she's flashing it it's
like
it's it's hefty but here's a snapshot of
the
almost like a dozen games there i call
this the meta games because
you can infuse um uh
changes to it and make it your own in
fact one of my favorite
uh meta game from here is
this uh game called speedboat um
primarily
i use this for example in design
thinking when we're just starting
um and and people are still the team is
still
struggling with identifying
what is really the problem and how do we
go about it and we're kind of like
swimming with um
so many details the way i would tweak it
is like
instead of a speed boat like it became a
a sailboat and and all the metaphors
that you can infuse
in into creating it creating a story
around it and just crystallizing
discussion
at the beginning of the design thinking
journey
this is quite helpful um you can also
see some
um some some games serious
innovation games here like buy a feature
i think you may have encountered that
uh quite recently um in many of the
design thinking projects that you have
encountered even 2020 vision
so have a go at this references
uh the materials that we're sharing with
you i'm sure there are 1001
materials out there but the idea is for
us um angela and i are trying to
make sense of the things that
we see there activities that are out
there in fact when you look at this
screen
i'm sharing with you it i think i may
need to just
make it a bit bigger for some yeah there
you go so
here is angela and i attempting to make
sense of all of this
um all of these um
activities we can we can define
the activity based on what
it is strongest act like in lsp for
example you you can
you can of course at this point have an
opinion of
lsp in terms of its ability to create
uh great metaphors and story sharing
in in if you encounter methods
kit cards for example um so for for
those that are unfamiliar it's
based out of europe if i'm not mistaken
really great fascinating
um provocation cards uh in ideation so
there are so many applications
application bit and if you scroll down
there there are a few more
you caught us you caught angela and i
still
trying to make sense of all of this and
as you can tell
serious play is is a big world um based
on how
we we've been like um uncovering all the
possibilities of adapting serious play
not only in design thinking but
designing their in problem solving and
long-term
uh long-term planning let me just
quickly
uh shift to the other slide and just so
you get a sense of how
we think creating this this matrix and
layering on top of design thinking
um then you we can probably uh
say for example if you are starting with
your design thinking journey
and and you want uh maybe a serious play
or a serious game that you can consider
for
the interview portion at the beginning
part or which is the empathy stage of a
design thinking
you can probably incorporate improv or
role play into it
and when you when you move into problem
definition or problem reframing
why not use the visual explorer cards uh
into it
and then of course when you move into um
the idea generation this is i think um
there's a buffet a smorgasbord of
options of serious play and serious game
you you can choose method
kit cards of course lego serious play is
strong it's from in in that um there are
a few more that you have an option rory
story q for example you can
still do that um it is when you move
into prototyping and validation that
it sometimes becomes a bit blurry in
terms of how serious play and serious
game can be applied but in fact
when we when we were exploring all of
this other serious playing serious games
when you create low fidelity prototyping
wow
you actually are engaging your
um your mind in in terms of when you're
developing prototype in a
in a playful manner and lastly when
you're
uh at this as a stage of validating it
with potential customers
um you can incorporate improve and role
play in
into it buy a feature if you know this
is
a an innovation game in that book that
we just mentioned a while ago so
aside from i think the main message at
this point is that
there is a big world or outside
of lego series today it is serious play
and
the idea of applying serious play into
it
okay i think at this point uh
let me invite some volunteers and i
think this is where angela and elite are
gonna help
help me identify some of you who may be
familiar
with mira already and some of you are
already there okay great
yes i did that already so in the
interest of tom darwin
i asked people who knew and a few people
came and if you could just come to this
board
for those five or six people who said
they are familiar with mirror obviously
we don't have time to teach people how
to use nero
yeah and so we thought we'd keep it
simple off you go yep
simple game uh it's a reinforcement why
even consider this game if you're
starting and you're struggling
with creating an environment where in
stories
story making and storytelling is a
foundation of the discussion
then the simple the simple game that
we're debuting today
would be maybe a good starter so hear me
out
uh before you start playing with that so
the the instruction here is quite simple
the six people that we have there on
board uh
i see you oh yep okay so the instruction
is quite simple
pick three icons that represents
for your that represents an answer to my
question which is what will you do
after this session what would you do
after this session using three icons
okay so you have like 30 seconds to pick
you pull them away yeah pull them away
like what i'm gonna do
i'm choosing one and then this one
and this is my story icon from what i
will do
after this session so go for it i see
things moving gretel is moving george is
still thinking
buying lim is there now okay don't
overtake have a look
it's just a fun way of incorporating
a an activity prior to what could be a
very heavy discussion on a lot of things
i think in the interest of time um i'll
probably
ask uh us to just stop
what we're going to be doing yeah
and then um at this point it's it's
really
a matter of sharing uh the story around
the three icons that you've chosen
so i think i see guest designer in this
instance fully complete so
may we ask uh guest designer
to come in and probably just a quick
share on what this these three icons
represent well what about let's pick on
job i mean you
you're unmuted go mr malaysia hello
yeah i couldn't unmute myself so that's
why sorry um yeah
thanks uh for giving me these
opportunity so uh
my icons are on the right it's a bicycle
a google sign like a dart board like a
focus thing
so i have i've never really witnessed or
experienced lego
serious play but i've heard about it
from both of you guys
at the play 14 last year so i was
curious about it
so that's a bit like the focus now i'm a
bit more focused and actually i have
some questions as well because i'm very
interested
in it and i would like to learn more
about it
then the google sign is also to do a bit
more googling after this
also especially especially the book
darwin talked about i wrote it down game
storming from o'reilly
so i'll see if i can find it and
yeah get some more information there
cool great
cool yeah the bicycle is i'm a dutchman
so
bicycle always relates to me and i come
by bike to work so later
uh today i will cycle back so i just
thought
that one has to be in as well yeah
awesome and just
yeah and just to run up that experience
is more of like we
we may we make it a bit more gamified by
having a contest
and by voting on the the most
interesting uh
most interesting uh story that has been
shared
i think we angela that's it right
checking on
yeah i think just the last one really
just maybe round off on why play in
design thinking and then i think we can
go
to uh q a after that okay
yeah sorry let me just yep and it's
really
why play i mean i mean at this point i
think i may rephrase it and why
seriously and why design thinking
seriously you know this enriches uh a
very humdrum
kind of activity in with work which is
what we normally associate play is fun
why not incorporate fun into our daily
lives and
where we were connecting teams um
building trust
um that's the you know a bad drop of
play
and when we look at it from a
problem-solving perspective it just
unlocks creativity and opens
a lot of you know new perspective or
directions when we
start discussing in the context or on
the around
play and yeah this is like i
i tell i tell everyone in terms of when
you're in the state of flow
um when you are at play um this is where
you are at your best um and this
having play just energizes you and
engages you
um when you incorporate into that one
and then maybe
darwin if you could just move on to the
miss
the mentee meter let's move on to the
next one i just wanted to say this is
really sort of the close of our
um seminar on serious play i'll let
narita talk about q a in a second but if
you
are interested in knowing a bit more and
go in depth this has obviously been a
lightning speed
quick we are running a program early
september
and i have a link to eventbrite if you
came to look at it a little bit further
we've already got
some ministry of education folks signed
up so we're super excited for that
but uh that's us narita over to you yep
thank you thank you thank you angela and
darwin for making
a three-hour session happen in 50
minutes i'm not sure how you got it done
but virtual lsp is the way forward
so big thanks for that um so we've got
obviously
um we've got a chat box going you've got
any questions like you're just kind of
put in the box we'll try to direct as
many questions as we can
towards them um but we're kind of maybe
you know for those who obviously seen
the breakout sessions we hope we got a
taster for what that experience is all
about
so we're going to maybe just start off
our first question
directed to angela first as we kind of
see through
the questions that are going to come
through shortly so the first one would
be
question one what are some of the
benefits of serious play
compared to traditional um engagement
workshops
angela so i think the thing about
workshops we know people have got their
smart devices they've got multiple
things
going on in their minds and multitasking
and i think the thing about serious play
is you
really cannot multitask you know when
you're playing lego and you're building
with these bricks quite frankly it's the
only thing that you're doing and i think
for me
it's one of the big benefits besides the
fact obviously that
you get breakthrough thinking and people
are able to unlock new knowledge
for me the big thing is that people are
present
they lean in they really co-create and
contribute and there's nothing else
that's really going on in their world so
for me that's the big big big
difference thank you angela
um so for this lsp methodology darwin um
how is it when is it best adopted is it
good for
employee engagement is it good for
design thinking
or you're trying to do leadership
visioning and you got guys in suits does
it work
yeah when can we use it when is it
appropriate
oh wow um i'm a big believer and a big
fan of lego serious play as part of
serious play
i employ serious play lego series play
in so many ways whenever it is
applicable
so if i'm for example uh in a service
design challenge
um we're creating a new one lsp is there
at the beginning of
the journey when we're trying to unravel
and untangle the question that they have
in even envisioning like when you have
strategic planning
uh or scenario creation lego serious
play comes into
play fun and pun intended in that in
that aspect
so um think of lego series play as
a fairly good meta game that you can
incorporate
meaning into it and you can extract a
lot of value in it
for so long as you know what it is that
you are
trying to address okay so one
interesting
question that just came up from cesar
who was a very interesting about direct
to you angela can lsp
use to create advertisement campaigns
nah interesting i want to say because in
the
the sort of creation of communications
there's a couple steps that happen right
and the first step is really
understanding who's this
communication for and what's our sort of
best
foot forward in terms of messaging and i
think lsp is very good
at defining what those parameters are
upfront so getting agreement
you know i worked in the advertising
industry not 20 years like narita said
but just 13 years and one of our biggest
challenges was always
what is the communication got to say and
what's it got to do for whom
and often we would come up with the with
the campaigns
and then we'd learn something later
about what we really wanted to do and
the client would sometimes say well no
that's not what we meant
and i wish i'd had lego series play back
then because i think
it'd clarify the brief really really
well up front
so not sure what can create the ads but
it definitely can set the conditions
to get the strategy right awesome
thank you i've got like so many good
questions coming up we'll see
so many good ones um we're going to
address the questions maybe
after when people kind of log off 11 30
um purpose of timing i'd like to maybe
just point the time over to
paul silvera from design singapore to
kind of give us updates
um in the play theme topic thank you
narita
uh i hope everyone can hear me and thank
you very much angela and darwin for that
awesome serious play
uh segment really enjoyed that so maybe
let me just introduce myself my name is
paul salvaraj from the design singapore
council
and i mean it's my great pleasure to
actually introduce you to the council in
this five to ten minute segment
and also actually go through some of the
programs
uh that we are you know we are bringing
out
and that would be of great relevance to
you so
uh design singapore council is actually
the national agency of design in
singapore
and you know our role and our vision
actually is for singapore to be an
innovation driven economy and a lovable
city by design
by 2025 right and our mission
is also you know developing the design
sector what we mean by that
is not only do we want to focus on you
know the traditional design fields
like fashion design furniture design
we're also all about the emerging fields
of design
like service design experience design
and even serious play as well
which angela and darwin mentioned and
you know we're always
on the lookout to help singapore use
design and innovation for
the future as you can tell i mean that's
something that's solely needed
as we navigate through these difficult
times and lastly uh making life better
through this
through design by designing for
different individuals and different
people
so i i was really interested in breakout
groom group one to actually listen to
all the different stories i heard
and all the different responses and i
think two things which i took away
was the very keen aspect on storytelling
which i thought everyone nailed very
well
as well as something around putting the
user at the center
of all conversations and i think i would
actually like you to
to uh sort of get these two aspects in
your mind
as we go forward and and talk about the
program so
design singapore actually has come up
with this program called design for
business user journey mapping
right about improving experiences for
customers by understanding users better
so as we heard about storytelling as we
heard about
uh you know envisioning things through
lego
we were actually thinking you know this
storytelling component
could be a good way in actually
visualizing your entire end-to-end user
journey
through sort of like a user journey map
so i think darwin went through that in
quite
length as well and we usually think that
this is a
good first step for com companies to
actually try and adopt
thinking through their users lands as
well as empathizing with their users
yeah so a typical example of a journey
map
would be something like this where we go
through an end-to-end
process of let's say a customer journey
in this case
through an online grocery store which i
think everyone has experience with
and we look through what the customer
says what the customer does
even what the customer thinks and feels
as he goes through the entire journey
as well as you know maybe identifying
areas of improvement
throughout the journey of where we could
actually innovate and improve on
so this is intended to be a very sort of
a quick
and fast way to actually quickly come up
with that full end-to-end journey and
get everyone on the same page of what
your customer is doing
so customer journey maps comes in all
shapes and sizes
it depends very much on the person or
the designer who's going through the
entire process
and what we find is that it's a very
quick way
for people to come together to to sort
of take stock of their existing customer
experience
and improve that as it goes on
so i mean no doubt undoubtedly user
journey mapping has actual tangible
benefits
uh identifying your user's pain points
and actually
thinking of ways to improve that is a
very very big factor in this process
and i guess the numbers speak for itself
this would be the main slide for
everyone to actually take note of
our user journey mapping program comes
in three different options
so we have option one and option two
which is on user journey mapping of your
customers
identifying areas of pain points and
also identifying some personas
right your hypothetical sort of user
archetypes that
you can actually focus on and you can
enjoy a 80
subsidy across all three options uh
until the end of 2020
and the final one would be around
service blueprinting
so that's slightly different if i could
just give a quick analogy of service
blueprinting
we have the front stage which is your
customer interaction
and you have your backstage so the
things happening behind the scenes
we believe that if you optimize your
backstage your front stage also
sort of gets the benefit as well and we
try not to look at
uh customer journey separately in that
in that aspect
cool uh i would i would very much like
to thank angela darwin again for that
great
session and you can indicate your
interest
in the schemes by scanning the qr code
on the left
or you could actually find out more
about the
options design singapore is hosting as
we move forward
and thank you again and over to you
narita
all right thank you everyone we're just
three minutes past 11 30.
thank you so much for your participation
we hope you gained some insights from
today's session
uh big thanks a round of applause for
for the entire kind of collaborative
team who's trying to make this who's
made this happen
so just on that thank you everyone for
your participation
we are going to try and address some of
the questions that's popped up in the
chat box that came up earlier so for
those of you who sent it you want to
stay on you're more than welcome to
but to everyone else who needs to go
with on with a busy friday afternoon
have a lovely day and thank again thank
you again for joining us
yeah thanks guys thanks also to the
paper space folks for
posting this and doing all the back of
house
organizing we really appreciate there's
a lot of hands behind the scenes
of course making this happen and of
course design singapore to
zeth and team paul michelle
from design singapore council thank you
so much i'm going to stay
on the call for a little bit because
i've got nothing else to do on a friday
um and so if you want to stay and have a
little chat we can but obviously
it is 10 sorry 11 35 and
we've kept two five minutes long sorry
all right thanks angela so while the the
kind of survey
feedback is happening i'm just gonna go
through some of the
questions that i thought were really
interesting um
first one was after that
add question let me find that question
way up
yeah yeah
okay would lsp be relevant for a team
building and team culture building
purpose
um and do you want to tackle christian
no i think darwin is a good
is perfect for this one
yes yes yes and yes
when when when you bring a team
especially
a newly formed team um
be bringing them into an environment of
play
uh creates that bond uh
quite quickly which is the objective of
what you're trying to do in any team
building exercise right
um what is it that they said um
bring me an hour get me into an hour
play and i will know you
more or better um and that's what
um brings out play uh
you get to know yourself you get to know
your team quite quickly
yeah and so lsp yes yes i'll just add to
that basically lego series play as a
methodology
is a it creates dialogue and so
you know dialogue is solely lacking and
i think you know one of the challenges
that we're
experiencing today with um you know
going through all of the challenges of
covet 19 and business continuity
is how do we bring people together and
how do we kind of like figure
out what's what's happening next and i
think lego series plays really good at
that to bring people together
to let people have a voice and to bring
them into the conversation
about what kind of company we want to be
because maybe there's having to be a big
reset around our focus
um so yeah very good for alignment
around vision
value strategy um and of course
new ideas uh as well so it's quite a
flexible system yeah okay that's the
next question from barath i think
and it's a good question it seems like a
good
approach or to disrupt pattern thinking
but can it be used for a more defined
challenge
yes so you want to you want to define
challenge you want to have like
it works really well when you have a
particular area of inquiry where you're
trying to understand i don't know
what's you know what's our next move as
an organization it can be very defined
you want to obviously leave it
sufficiently open
that you're going to invite people to
bring their thoughts and feelings into
the workshop
and so i would say where it doesn't work
so well
is where you have an agenda and you want
to tell people something
and you want to tell them to think
something and i think that's where it's
a little tricky
when you use it to force something on
people
it needs to you know live to the values
of lego series play which is that this
vast untapped potential sitting around
us and um we need to elicit though
that feedback into the process so a
focus is helpful
um are we thinking about next year's
plan are we thinking about
a particular customer a particular
market
or even a product one product that we
want to like rethink
and i think that's where when it becomes
serious
rather than just play if you have an an
aim or an idea that a defined
challenge um then it becomes serious
play because
there is a point where you're just
playing um
and it's unstructured in free flow
yeah yeah excellent anymore
question from vivian um it says
it's an interesting question where
during the sharing session
i would like to hear more about whether
the workshop
participants changed
in terms of true experiences and
i'm not sure it begins with us but what
sort of change were you maybe referring
to
point of view behavior culture
were you seeing some of that angela with
our crazy work with you
yes no i think um the real success
is when you know when we go to a meeting
often when we know the agenda of that
meeting and we know what we're trying to
do we can actually go in with a script
you know we go in knowing our point of
view and we want to hit our point of
view across
lego series play tries to sort of
disrupt that script
and so what you're trying to do is
you're trying to move people
either in understanding what's what what
situation do we find ourselves in how do
we as an organization need to
change because of this new situation and
so
it helps to sort of shift people to see
maybe another perspective
um and so yes i mean the objective is to
for people to leave that workshop
changed in some way
by having some kind of eureka maybe
some new understanding and of course
ultimately in lego series play you want
to make sure that there's some
action you know where do we take this
um so yeah i think definitely people
walk away hopefully
a little bit um a little bit uh shifted
in some way
transform one last question from rachel
it's really interesting because her
question resides with me
having worked with us um
has there been any opportunity to work
with top-tier consulting firms like
mckinsey
uh to use lsp to engage
top management on strategy sessions
have you have any experiences of similar
setups well i know that it's used
extensively with senior leadership
and i have in fact i've had ceos in my
session and i know that the big
consultancies are actually toying with
lego serious play we in our community
darwin we've got some folks from
like deloitte and kpmg and boston
consulting group so they are dabbling in
it
um i think culturally it may not be a
perfect fit for those
typical sort of management consultancies
but some are seeing the light
and it works very well i think with
senior leaders who can be a bit too much
in their head sometimes
and it's it's a such a great equalizer
do you know when you have
the ceo in the room sitting alongside
one of his managers building and sharing
and you're not
everyone gets the same airtime but
nobody can
no one can dominate the conversation
um i know that when i talk with clients
and we commission projects often they
say
you know how is it going to be having
the ceo
or the leadership team in the room and i
always say it's great
because they're they're they're
listening they're part of the dialogue
it's very important
so yes definitely done with senior
leaders and i would say that actually
they need it more because they really do
need to get out of their own heads
absolutely angela and having sort of
facilitated the session
last march i think some of the feedback
we got from participants is very
interesting
is that it's it's non-judgmental
workshops you kind of have to have to
prime yourself for the perfect answer
there is no perfect answer and there are
no wrong answers in lsp
so whatever you do is as good as the
next person because it's your point of
view and it's a safe space
to do that yeah i think just on that
point
narita i remember i think telling you
the market in the world where
lego series play has the greatest demand
in other words we are the most
facilitators outside of north america
which is because it's had a long history
is actually in japan
and there's a good reason for that and
that is because
the methodology allows frank
conversations that can be quite
difficult
yes and definitely very difficult in
very hierarchical organizations and
hierarchical cultures
where juniors are afraid to speak up
right
and lego series play is the ultimate
sort of equalizer
yeah it's your metaphor your story
making storytelling comes
into play but i think i wanted what i
wanted also add on
lego series play i think what i like is
the persistence of the memory that you
build when
when you are doing lego series play i
can come back on organization
after a year and they will still refer
to the model by heart
and will point to the different bricks
because of the different meanings that
have become
that have been shared and has been
communicated to the organization so the
the persistence of the
memory that you make when you're playing
lingers on
and there's a tangible model in one hand
so this is a very good last question i
can't see your name here but it kind of
ends everything really well
which is um you know when you look at
when
i have the same problem as well when i
try to put it to clients they're like
that's great for everyone else but
ourselves
um so how do you kind of uh really vary
for person
and the question is you know you know
what about
how do you dress discomfort of
participants who are not comfortable
with play
in a work setting i think that's a very
valid question
or feel that participating in lsp is too
unstructured
[Music]
depression i haven't met anyone who
doesn't want to play
but but i understand the cultural
sort of in a workplace context that
might sort of
feel out of place
[Music]
i think what we do darwin is we do these
demo sessions with clients
exactly yes you have to put
people in a room and you have to show
how it works and create comfort around
the bricks and building and more
importantly the significance um
and the productive output that comes
from the video
so so i feel like that's um
that's a big one we always have to tell
people it's serious play it's not play
yeah and the serious bit
um is really that there's some heavy
thinking going on
um and you know i think
when i'm talking to a client and they
are sort of worried
they're both sides right the one is that
um it's too playful
and then you have to play up the fact
that actually this this is serious and
there's
a huge structure and the reason why
darwin and i are sort of
have done the certifications is because
the designing of the questions
is really important and designing of
what is the outcome right
and we we would spend hours
brainstorming
sort of what's the best journey you want
to create so
it's highly structured it's not just a
whole bunch of bricks right darwin i
mean
i so totally agree with you and i think
it's that reinforcement of what you
mentioned earlier
uh when you were answering the retest
question i mean
for that one i think it's one thing for
us to tell
you about lsp but it is also one
other thing for you to experience it
yourself before you
form an opinion because only when you
play it
uh even with just a few short minutes i
mean we went through like 20 minutes
with just
that and um i i'm looking at the
comments in the chat i was like
forming ideas and opinions already on
that
so yeah um i i so agree
and who doesn't love this kind of things
when it's already like
they're in front of you yeah i mean we
have the best job in the world when we
bring people into a room
and there's a pile of bricks on the
table i mean you know my life is not
terrible
um and um people sort of the energy
changes we
are doing a huge favor when they see the
bricks but then the real work starts and
i always tell people it's not balloons
and half-harving and fun fun fun
um i have my i've got my german roots
and i'm all business
um and it's all about like let's get
going and let's get the output and so
it's very
output driven it's very structured um
it's serious
yeah and i get a and i get a lot of um
after they've gone through it it's like
hey darwin that was really exhausting
fulfilling but exhausting was like
they were not expecting it to be that
way i mean you know
seriously there is still the play yeah
we they were in the flow of doing that
but then
when they they tell me like oh it's like
i went to therapy or i'm
too exhausted now like oh wow then it
just tells you how
um powerful serious play in general
could be
yeah absolutely so ladies and gentlemen
it is 11 48
i have another call it's been i don't
understand
thanks everyone bye
[Music]